hello guys my name is Chan oh and
welcome to the first episode of the
second season of game programming so it
has been around for years since the
beginning of the km programming series
it's been a very long season if you can
call that 126 episodes go into the first
season and that took about four years
which is pretty crazy and so what I
decided was this series really lacked
proper direction I wasn't really giving
this series anyway any serious attention
which is which was a bit of a shame and
really what what I decided to do it was
sit down and actually plan out what was
gonna happen here and essentially what
I've decided to do and this is kind of
what I've what I plan to do really is
end this series all right like as in
it's a little bit sad but it's also like
I sat down to figure out how I would end
the series and obviously I have to
finish the game I can't just be like
yeah okay this is it we're calling it
quits that's it no what I mean is I sat
down to plan how this would end and how
and everything that would have to go
into it to kind of to plan out the end
right and don't worry if you like this
series don't worry because there is a
lot of stuff that still needs to get
done so we're gonna have a probably at
least another 100 episodes or so but I
am going to make sure that instead of
doing random things here in there I'm
actually following some kind of concrete
plan and that plan starts here today
with multiplayer so what we're gonna do
first in this new thing is multiplayer
and I'm kind of gonna break it up into
seasons in the in the sense of though
it's probably gonna be like 20 or so
episodes per season and that way we can
kind of you can watch like a season of
game programming and then you get like a
certain knowledge set right it's it's
it's gonna be structured a little bit
differently than the previous kind of
126 episodes which were more or less
kind of random I've also changed kind of
the format of the videos a little bit so
first of all hello this is me
there's a facecam now for all game
programming episodes the reason is I
started using it more and more in my
regular videos and I found
people were generally more interested in
watching videos that had the FaceCam in
them of course I mean why would you not
want to see my face am i right but in
all honesty in all honesty I mean I also
enjoy watching other people's videos
where they have the FaceCam it kind of
just feels a bit more natural and you
know when I'm doing stuff like right now
I'm just talking to you guys and I'm not
doing anything on the screen right it
still kind of attracts your attention
whereas if there's no FaceCam I'm always
tempted to click away if they're not
really doing anything so this this
hopefully will at least get some
movement going on in the screen while
I'm just talking but anyway the deal is
new game programming 15 to 20-minute
episodes or 10 to 20-minute episodes is
gonna be kind of the goal instead of
episodes ranging from 5 minutes to an
hour and there's gonna be a proper
release schedule which a lot of people
are gonna be interested in and by
release schedule what I mean is
basically these videos are gonna go up
every single Sunday night at 9:30 p.m.
Australian Eastern Standard Time okay so
you can just use the time zone converter
to convert that into whatever your time
zone is but every Sunday is going to be
a recurring kind of Sunday sure where
9:30 p.m. espera needs in Santa time
you'll be able to tune in to watch the
latest episode of game programming so
anyway let's not spend too much time
talking let's actually do something the
first thing I want to mention is that
all of the code here is on github right
now it's a private repository which you
can get access to if you support me on
patreon so if you support me with at
least $5 per month then you get access
to this game programming repository
right and it doesn't have to be like a
per month thing you can just pledge for
like one month and then get access and
that's it
right and then you can obviously clone
the repository so I encourage you guys
to do that first of all because it's
gonna support this series and ensure
that I actually do make more of these
videos but the second reason is that you
guys will get a clean kind of check out
of the code right because what you
probably have now if you
have the code at all is going to be a
pretty long kind of four year in the
making of kind of version of the source
code right and you might have copied
bits down wrong you might not have you
might have made arrows you might have
changed stuff yourself anyway it's just
a lot easier if you grab this code if
you want to of course otherwise you can
go back and watch 126 episodes which I
also encourage you to do actually
because that'll probably teach you a lot
the second time around or whatever
however many times you may have watched
them rewashing stuff is always useful
but what I'm dealing with here is a
clean check out of exactly the of
exactly this commit right which is
episode 126 the other thing I wanted to
mention was apart from you know if you
pledge five dollars or more per month
apart from just getting access to this
kind of game programming like the source
code that I type you also get access to
stuff that you don't see in these
episodes like for example I've got a
branch here called multiplayer which
already has a good deal you can see it's
completely different it's Oliver and
sort of got like a rain server project
and everything and that's already kind
of somewhat got like all this all this
stuff implemented right and that's stuff
that I usually work on during live
streams because obviously as I mentioned
I wanted to make these these episodes a
little bit more kind of structure
structured a little bit more concise and
I know I say concise but I'm I haven't
actually even started the episode yet
but that's just because this is the
first episode of the second season and I
have to get all this out but the point
is because I've kind of wanted to make
this actually a bit more professional
and stuff I've started kind of pre
writing the code more or less instead of
just doing it live and because of that
you can kind of access the development
branches if you have access to that
repository so highly recommend you guys
do that and then if you do do that you
will receive this code so let's begin
the first thing I wanted to do and this
is the reason why I don't even have
Eclipse open is I actually want to kind
of sort this out the reason is what we
have right now is the root project
there's only one project in the
repository I know we've kind of got the
civilization episode and all that but
we'll set that up properly in a minute
here but essentially what we need to do
is solve this out so that it's it's
actually in a proper folder
so what I want to do with all this code
is because I haven't committed the
civilization stuff really into this
repository because of the issue that
everything was kind of in this folder
like the entire rain repository is just
kind of one project and it needs to be
multiple so what I want to do is I'm
going to create a new folder and I want
to call it rain right that'll be our
main game I want to copy everything into
it except for the dot git folder in this
case because I don't want to remove that
right and then what I'm going to do is
actually let me quickly jot down here
what if I want to do I wanted to grab
the rain cloud civilization folder which
you can get from github that one is
actually a public repository and then
that contains all the sterilization
source code I'm going to make sure that
that's also in this folder so we have a
folder called rain we have a folder
called rain class terrorization and this
is this folder this folder in itself is
going to be the workspace folder so if
we boot up Eclipse what you will be able
to do is just essentially navigate your
workspace to be this folder right so
I'll do that right now switch workspace
other and then I'll paste in this path
here and I'll hit OK and this is gonna
set up a new workspace you can see you
can see it's got the adult metadata fold
and now which means that it's an eclipse
workspace I can probably remove that
icon thing and then if we just go to our
workbench well what you should see is a
brand new Eclipse and we're gonna kind
of fix that but essentially that's
because the workspace like wasn't
committed I'm gonna quickly set this up
the way I like it this is also really
nice because if you guys are just tuning
in now into game programming then all
you'll see me do here is set everything
out the way I like it
but the important things we need to do
in either the Navigator or the package
Explorer is create a new Java project
and called the exact same name as our
two folders essentially so first we'll
do rain then we'll do rain clouds
realization right so we have rain hit
finish
and then we'll create a new Java project
with the name rain cloud series ation
all right
and there we have that so now that we've
got that set up they should be linked
together somewhat you can say that all
the icons are showing up with question
of access just because git does not
recognize these files or anything like
that because just because we haven't
committed them essentially we haven't
like trapped them because we've moved
directories and everything but the first
thing I'll do is I'll set up this font
so if I go window preferences you guys
don't need to do this but the reason I'm
doing it is just so that you guys could
see better so Gonzalez 16 I think was
pretty good all right well it's so big
not sorry I'm gonna make this 14 I
actually struggled to write like it's a
lot harder to see what you're doing you
have the fonts that big which is why I
kind of like 14 is gonna be pretty much
as big as I ever make it so if you guys
can't see this you might want to
fullscreen the video and make sure
you're watching it in full HD but um
what we'll do here is make sure that the
serialization libraries link I'm not
sure I don't expect it will be I mean if
we try and run this because we do have
since last time we did this whole saving
and loading stuff from ASCII database it
actually does look like it is linked
though but I may have just where exactly
is this okay so it isn't here I guess
it's automatically realized that it's
linked or something if we go into the
build path projects yeah okay so
required project
projects for the build path is it's
already set up if it wasn't you can
basically just hit add and then just
take the rank class realization right
and you should get everything in the
right place so what this did was
essentially just let us save our window
size I think and yeah width height scale
right this was just an example of how to
use this er ization library that we were
at but there you go so it will basically
just load that size in and yeah cool all
right brilliant so we've got the basic
setup of what we're going to do
our like let me rephrase that we've got
the basic setup of of where we're going
to implement multiplayer from so make
sure you guys have set it up exactly the
same way that I have and apart from that
I think we're ready to go
so what I'm gonna do for the rest of
this episode is just discuss the plan
for the next like 10 or 20 episodes
right so we're gonna have just one
episode of planning I'm not gonna spend
three or so episodes just planning this
out because I'd really like personally
I'm not a huge fan of planning now when
I say that I don't mean I don't like to
plan or I don't like to you know come up
with ideas and stuff before I implement
them no it's nothing like that
what I mean is I am like what what a lot
of people end up doing is is essentially
spending time planning instead of
actually doing the work right so for
example you know instead of actually
sitting down and beginning to solve your
problems you have meetings or you talked
about how you're going to solve your
problems or how you should solve your
problems right
whereas what you should be doing is
actually spending time implementing the
damn thing
so I'm definitely not going to like in
that in that sense I know it like I
don't like planning too much because
over planning means that you're wasting
time essentially and I I don't like
doing that so what I'm going to do is
we're gonna kind of literally just 3 min
a plan sesh right now because I already
know what I'm doing anyway and you guys
can post your comments about whether or
not you think my plan is a good one
I mean it's gonna be a very high-level
plan so there's not really too much you
can fault with it I don't I don't think
and then starting next episode episode 2
of season 2 we're going to actually
start writing code so first off
multiplayer right the idea is the way
that this is gonna work is we're gonna
make a new project called rain cloud
server alright or just rain server right
and that's going to be our server so the
way we're gonna set this up is going to
be like a client-server architecture
right so there's going to be multiple
clients and they're all going to connect
to one server we're not going to pretend
that this game is going to be it it's
like a hugely scalable game isn't we're
not going to write our code in such a
way that
we'll scale up to thousands of them
thousands of players right I don't care
about that our goal our initial goal is
just going to be to support a hundred
people right if we can get a hundred
players connected into this server then
it's going to be just it's gonna be a
success right this is a small series on
how to make a game in Java I'm not gonna
pretend that it's gonna support millions
of people and I'm not gonna spend time
writing code that will ensure that level
of scalability okay
our goal is 100 users and that's what
we're gonna target which is gonna be
really easy because at that at that kind
of level of scale you really don't have
to take March into consideration right
if you write your code half decently
it's gonna just be able to support that
out of the box right you don't need to
do like load balancing or any kind of
you know distribution or anything like
that it should just work right because
that's not that many people that being
said though we are gonna have a single
server and we are gonna have multiple
clients being able to connect to that
server that servers going to manage the
clients kind of lifetime right so the
server's gonna be in charge of just
making sure that the clients are still
connected making sure that clients send
and receive information in the correct
fashion it's going to do some kind of
validation as well to make sure the
clients aren't cheating it's going to
make sure that the clients can send
information to each other right so for
example private messages from one client
arrive at the other client and so you
can have essentially destinations
instead of just being able to for
example broadcast your position to all
other clients if you're in the game you
can also send messages directly to a
single client we're going to ensure that
we are sending our using as a little
bandwidth as possible right and ensuring
that any kind of packet loss it doesn't
affect gameplay right so it might you
might lose a few frames of movement for
example but you're not going to
completely eye crash or anything like
that
and you're not going to like that there
shouldn't be any kind of synchronization
issues where what you see on one client
is going to be different than the other
client even though they're both
connected and there
Naser live right so no synchronization
issues we're not going to bother with
encryption okay i'm not going to encrypt
the packers or anything of that the
reason is it's going to be it's very
trivial to encrypt packets with some
kind of key some kind of what's the term
I was looking for you know if you have
like a key store or something like a
public private key or something like
that and you want to encrypt that that's
fine you can do that I'm not gonna cover
that in this series because we don't
really need to and because again it's
really trivial to implement yourself so
I don't really want to make waste time
on that again we're not trying to build
something that is going to be completely
hack proof or completely scalable right
we're just making a small game and we
just need it to work for a hundred and
kind of like a hundred or so users which
we assume are not going to try and hack
us right that being said though we
aren't gonna write bad code okay we are
going to write good code we are going to
write code that like for its size will
actually like will work properly and
shouldn't contain too many bugs right at
least we'll we'll make sure that it's
basically rock-solid right and more
importantly as well we will still
implement some kind of anti cheating
stuff right it's just it's not going to
be to the level of hey let's encrypt
packets and make sure that people can't
set send false packets and stuff like
that right it's going to be a little bit
more relaxed than that but that's
basically the plan so when I have a
server we're gonna set up a server
project we're just going to be a
standalone application it's gonna accept
clients when you start up the game over
here in your startup code when you're
basically you know initializing
everything you'll probably do the screen
the UI manager the driver and the
keyboard all of this stuff initially
then we're going to connect to the
server right we're going to essentially
ask the user to login so there's gonna
be some kind of login so they login with
their details and then from there it's
going to retrieve like which level to
load what items the player has
I know we haven't even really covered
items but we're gonna have to write
we're gonna set up the bait that like
the bare minimum for multiplayer I mean
our game right now support stuff like
shooting and moving around so that's
pretty much all we're going to implement
in multiplayer but we will set up the
framework in such a way so that when we
do add items to the game for example we
can easily hook that up through our
server right it's not going to be an
issue of you know we have to now spend
some time working on our server again to
support items no it should be able to
supply everything right even even if the
client doesn't because really when you
think about it the client server kind of
the multiplayer aspect of this game is
just going to be a way to transmit
information between clients and the
server that's all it is it's going to be
that communication layer right what you
can what you communicate right your
communication content that is going to
be completely client-side okay the
server will need code for stuff like
anti cheating and being able to save
items and you know provide the client
with certain information upon logging in
and all that stuff and obviously in that
case we will have to modify it the
server but that again is extremely high
level right the actual low level
implementations will be done and dusted
in the next few episodes essentially
okay cool all right I'm gonna wrap out
this episode here cuz it's approaching
the 20 minute mark and I've said
everything I wanted to say that's how
it's gonna work post your thoughts in
the comment section below if you like
the video please hit the like button of
course and I'll see you guys next Sunday
with episode 2 goodbye